vous serez bien ici avec d'autres
abulenses comme toi
Tu verras papa ici tu auras tout
que pensez-vous de la cellule
Je suis Miguel votre colocataire
mon nom est emilio ravi de
rendez-vous la salle à manger
la bibliothèque dont les lavabos font partie
les infirmières sont un bon gars malgré
pour porter ces trois sont traîne miguel
Que pensez-vous de la résidence ?
un peu étrange d'être ici au début
c'est naturel
J'étais directeur de banque et barbare
tu es un autre rockefeller comme ça
forme vous voyez que vous devez toucher le genou
avec la main pour vos douleurs et
modeste emilio, ne vois-tu pas ce qui t'est arrivé
mettre la vidéo de mon viagra hey avec ça
la barbe ressemble à papa ce qu'il m'a dit
le même chaque jour devrait être un
erreur d'avoir emilio alzheimer n'a pas
un traitement spécifique ne me va pas
maison
Je ne porte rien de xerez maintenant avant que tu ne doives le faire
enlever vos vêtements peut-être dans un
Je ne sais même plus qui je suis mais dans ce
moment où je suis vivant
[Musique]
les vents
et libre